♪ ♪
>> Tucker: GOOD EVENING, AND
WELCOME TO
"TUCKER CARLSON TONIGHT."
WE TAKE A LOT OF DIGS AT THE
MEETING ON THIS SHOW, AND WE DO
IT FOR RHETORICAL REASONS.
IT’S FUN, AND THEY DESERVE IT.
RECENTLY, WE HAVE WATCHED WITH
GROWING AMUSEMENT AS OUR MEDIA
GATEKEEPERS THRASH AROUND IN A
FRENZY OF FOAMING HYSTERIA OVER
THE POSSIBILITY THAT SOMEONE,
SOMEWHERE, MIGHT DARE TO PRESENT
FACTS OR FORM OPINIONS WITHOUT
THEIR EXPRESS WRITTEN PERMISSION
PERMISSION.
FREELANCE THINKING IS WHAT THEY
HATE MOST.
IT IS A THREAT TO THEIR
MONOPOLY.
WE CAN’T SAY THAT OUT LOUD, SO
INSTEAD THEY CALLED IT
"DISINFORMATION!"
DISINFORMATION IS THE REAL
THREAT, SAYS THE GUY WHO THINKS
HIS UNION HAS THE CONTRACT ON
BRINGING YOU THE NEWS.
IT’S RIDICULOUS.
BUT BEFORE YOU JUDGE THESE
PEOPLE, TAKE A MOMENT AND FEEL
SOME COMPASSION AND FIGURE HOW
THEY MIGHT BE FEELING RIGHT
ABOUT NOW.
IMAGINE IF YOU HAD SPENT 30
YEARS MAKING A GOOD LIVING AS A
CAR MECHANIC, AND ALL OF A
SUDDEN, GM INVENTS AN ENGINE
THAT ANYONE CAN FIX AT HOME WITH
A SCREWDRIVER.
YOU’D BE UPSET.
THAT’S HOW CNN FEELS ABOUT THE
INTERNET.
IT’S EXPOSING THEIR SCAM.
NATURALLY, THEY ARE A LITTLE
IRRATIONAL ABOUT IT.
>> MILLIONS OF AMERICANS CLAIM
TO CONSPIRACY THEORIES.
THIS IS ALL EVIDENCE OF
RADICALIZATION.
AND THAT’S NOT EASY TO SAY.
IT’S NOT AN EASY WORD TO USE.
BUT IT’S WAY PAST TIME TO TALK
ABOUT THIS HONESTLY.
NO ONE SHOULD TIPTOE PAST THIS
PREDICAMENT.
DISINFORMATION NETWORKS LIKE
QANON ARE CAUSING PEOPLE TO LOSE
TOUCH WITH REALITY.
>> Tucker: DISINFORMATION
NETWORKS?
THAT DOESN’T SOUND LIKE A
MISLEADING SOCIAL MEDIA POST.
IT SOUNDS LIKE A TERROR CELL.
AND IT SOUNDS THAT WAY ON
PURPOSE.
THE THING ABOUT DISINFORMATION,
THEY ARE TELLING US, IT IS NOT
SIMPLY HARMFUL TO YOU
PERSONALLY, IT’S NOT LIKE EATING
A OF BEN & JERRY’S OR SNEAKING A
SMOKE WHILE THE KIDS ARE AT
SCHOOL.
NO, DISINFORMATION IS NOT A SIN,
IT IS A CRIME, DISINFORMATION
HURTS EVERYONE, IT IS AN OFFENSE
AGAINST THIS COUNTRY.
DISINFORMATION IS AN ATTACK ON
AMERICA, AND NOT JUST ON
AMERICA.
BUT MORE CRITICALLY COME ON
SOMETHING CALLED OUR NORMS.
>> OUR NORMS ARE SO OUT OF WHACK
THAT IT HAS BECOME SURPRISING
WHEN GOOD THINGS HAPPEN.
>> EVEN AFTER FOUR YEARS OF
TALKING NIGHT AFTER NIGHT ABOUT
THE NORMS THAT ARE BEING
SHATTERED.
>> HE IS DOING EVERYTHING TO
SHRED EVERY ONE OF THESE NORMS.
>> WE CAN’T ALLOW THESE KIND OF
DEMOCRATIC NORMS TO BE
SHATTERED.
>> WE HAVE ABIDED BY THESE
NORMS, BUT THIS RESIDENT AND
ADMINISTRATION HAS JUST BLOWN
RIGHT THROUGH THOSE NORMS.
>> NOT SINCE THE RED SCARE HAVE
ONCE GOOD MEN AND WOMEN BEEN
DRAGGED INTO THIS KIND OF
SABOTAGE OF OUR DEMOCRACY AND
SOCIAL NORMS.
>> Tucker: OUR NORMS.
SHATTERED.
SHREDDED.
CRUSHED.
DESTROYED.
BONE THROUGH.
WHY IS IT ALWAYS OUR NORMS THAT
ARE THE FIRST TO BE ATTACKED?
MAY BE BECAUSE OUR NORMS ARE
DEMOCRACIES FIRST RESPONDERS.
THEY RUN TO THE SOUND OF
GUNFIRE.
NORMS ARE LIKE THE YOUNG
LIEUTENANT IN VIETNAM WALKING
THROUGH THE RICE PATTIES,
EXPOSING THEMSELVES TO FIRE
ORDERS TO SAVE THE PLATOON.
NEVER MORE SO THAN NOW.
YOU THOUGHT UNDERWATER WELDING
WAS A TREACHEROUS GIG?
YOU FEAR FOR THE GUYS WHO FIX
ANTENNAS ON SKYSCRAPERS?
THAT IS NOTHING.
IMAGINE BEING A NORM IN TODAY’S
AMERICA.
THEY DON’T LAST LONG.
OKAY, WE WILL STOP.
IT IS ALL AMUSING AND HARD TO
RESIST, OUR NORMS, OUR NORMS!
ON THE OTHER HAND, BEING
COMPLETELY HONEST HERE -- WE
STRIVE TO BECOME FULLY HONEST --
THAT WE HAVE TO ADMIT THERE IS A
KERNEL OF TRUTH AND WHAT THEY
ARE YELLING ABOUT.
THERE IS DISINFORMATION OUT
THERE AND IT DOES HURT PEOPLE,
AND MAKES PEOPLE STUPID, FOR ONE
THING.
IT ALSO IMPAIRS THEIR ABILITY TO
MAKE WISE DECISIONS.
YOU CANNOT KNOW WHAT TO DO NEXT
IF YOU DO NOT KNOW WHAT IS
REALLY GOING ON.
A LOT OF PEOPLE IN THIS COUNTRY
ARE IN THAT POSITION RIGHT NOW.
WE SAW EVIDENCE OF IT JUST THIS
WEEK.
WRITE A RESEARCH PAPER CALLED
"HOW INFORMED OUR AMERICANS
ABOUT RACE AND POLICING?"
PUBLISHED BY THE SKEPTIC
RESEARCH CENTER.
CHECK IT OUT ONLINE IF YOU HAVE
NOT READ IT, IT IS A PRETTY
AMAZING DOCUMENT.
THE RESEARCHERS ASKED PEOPLE TO
ESTIMATE THE NUMBER OF UNARMED
AFRICAN-AMERICANS WHO WERE
KILLED BY THE POLICE IN 2019.
HERE ARE THE RESULTS.
44% OF AMERICANS WHO DESCRIBE
THEMSELVES AS LIBERAL BELIEVE
THE TOTAL NUMBER OF KILLED WAS
"A THOUSAND OR MORE."
MORE THAN A THOUSAND UNARMED
AFRICAN-AMERICANS GONE DOWN BY
COPS.
IS THAT TRUE?
WELL, AS IT HAPPENS, WE HAVE
DEFINITIVE STATISTICS, PUBLICLY
AVAILABLE, YOU CAN FIND THEM IN
ABOUT A MINUTE.
THE ACTUAL NUMBER OF UNARMED
AFRICAN-AMERICANS KILLED BY THE
POLICE IN 2019 WAS 27.
SO, MORE THAN A THOUSAND VERSUS
THE REALITY OF 27.
QUITE A SPREAD.
AND IT WAS NOT AN ANOMALY.
THE REST OF THE STUDY FOUND
SIMILAR RESULTS.
SELF-DESCRIBED LIBERALS, FOR
EXAMPLE, BELIEVE A STRONG
MAJORITY OF PEOPLE KILLED BY
POLICE IN 2019 WERE
AFRICAN-AMERICAN.
THE ACTUAL PERCENTAGE WAS LESS
THAN HALF THAT, CLOSER TO 25%.
THESE ARE NOT SMALL MISTAKES.
A LOT OF AMERICANS ARE
COMPLETELY AND UTTERLY
MISINFORMED, AND THAT HAS ACTUAL
CONSEQUENCES.
PUBLIC POLICY CAN CHANGE
DRAMATICALLY IN THE FACE OF
THINGS PEOPLE THINK THEY KNOW
THEY DON’T ACTUALLY KNOW, AND WE
HAVE SEEN THAT A LOT.
ENTIRE POLICE DEPARTMENT GOT
DEFUNDED.
SO IT IS WORTH FINDING OUT WHERE
THE PUBLIC IS GETTING ALL THIS
FALSE INFORMATION, THIS
DISINFORMATION, AS WE WILL CALL
IT.
SO WE CHECKED.
WE SPENT ALL DAY TRYING TO
LOCATE THE FAMOUS QANON, WHICH
IN THE END WE LEARNED IS NOT
EVEN A WEBSITE.
IF IT’S OUT THERE, WE CANNOT
FIND IT FAIR THAT WE CHECKED
MARJORIE TAYLOR GREENE’S TWITTER
FEED BECAUSE WE HAVE HEARD YOU
TRAFFICS IN MISINFORMATION, CNN
TOLD US, BUT NOTHING THERE.
NEXT WE CALLED OUR MANY FRIENDS
IN THE TIGHT-KNIT INTEL
COMMUNITY.
COULD VLADIMIR PUTIN BE PUTTING
THIS STUFF OUT THERE?
THE PROUD BOYS?
ALEX JONES?
WHO IS LYING TO AMERICA IN WAYS
THAT ARE CERTAIN TO MAKE US HATE
EACH OTHER AND CERTAIN TO
DESTROY OUR CORE INSTITUTIONS?
WELL, NONE OF THE ABOVE,
ACTUALLY.
IT WAS ON MARJORIE TAYLOR
GREENE.
IT WAS CABLE NEWS.
IT WAS POLITICIANS TALKING ON
TV.
THEY ARE THE ONES SPREADING
DISINFORMATION TO AMERICANS.
MAYBE THEY ARE FROM QANON.
YOU BE THE JUDGE.
>> WE HAVE A LONG AND WRETCHED
AND DISTURBING HISTORY IN THIS
COUNTRY OF BLACK PEOPLE BEING
MURDERED BY LAW ENFORCEMENT.
>> TRAINING FOR POLICE OFFICERS
ON IMPLICIT RACIAL BIAS AND
PROCEDURAL JUSTICE, BECAUSE TO
DENY IT EXISTS IS TO DENY FOLKS
LIBERTY, AND IN MANY CASES,
LIFE.
>> HOW DO WE CONTINUE TO LOSE
LIVES OF UNARMED BLACK MEN IN
THE UNITED STATES OF AMERICA AT
THE HANDS OF WHITE POLICE
OFFICERS?
>> I NEVER HAD TO TELL MY
DAUGHTER, IF SHE IS PULLED OVER,
MAKE SURE SHE PUTS -- A TRAFFIC
STOP -- PUT BOTH HANDS ON TOP OF
THE WHEEL AND DON’T REACH FOR
THE GLOVE BOX, BECAUSE SOMEONE
MAY SHOOT YOU.
>> Tucker: SO NOT ONLY ARE
HUGE NUMBERS OF UNARMED
AFRICAN-AMERICANS MURDERED EVERY
YEAR BECAUSE OF THEIR RACE, TO
DENY THAT OR QUESTION THAT FACT
IS TO EFFECTIVELY PARTICIPATE IN
THOSE KILLINGS ARE SELF.
DENYING THIS IS DENYING THEM
LIFE, AS KAMALA HARRIS PUT IT.
OR I CNN SAID, IT IS MASS
MURDER.
>> NO, I’M NOT TELLING PEOPLE TO
GO THERE AND RIOT, BUT TELL ME
WHAT THE PROPORTIONAL RESPONSE
TO MASS MURDER OVER THE YEARS
IS?
WHAT IS A PROPORTIONAL RESPONSE
TO THAT?
>> Tucker: I’M NOT TELLING
PEOPLE TO GO OUT AND RIOT, BUT
WHAT IS THE PROPORTIONAL
RESPONSE TO MASS MURDER?
GOOD QUESTION, CNN.
BURNING WENDY’S, OBVIOUSLY.
BUT WHERE ARE YOU ASKING, THIS
IS THE MISSING PIECE.
THE CHANNEL CLAIMED COPS HAD
TRIED TO EXECUTE AN UNARMED
AFRICAN-AMERICAN MAN CALLED
JACOB BLAKE IN WISCONSIN.
AND THEY REPEATED THE CLAIM
JACOB BLAKE WAS UNARMED AGAIN
AND AGAIN AND AGAIN.
>> NO CHARGES WILL BE BROUGHT
AGAINST THE POLICE OFFICER, OR
ANY OF THE POLICE OFFICERS
INVOLVED IN THE SHOOTING OF
JACOB BLAKE.
AN UNARMED BLACK MAN WHO WAS
SHOT.
>> VIEWERS MAY RECALL AN OFFICER
SHOT BLAKE IN THE MAN SEVEN
TIMES WHILE HE WAS UNARMED.
>> ANOTHER EXAMPLE OF
AFRICAN-AMERICANS NOT RECEIVING
EQUAL PROTECTION OF LAW.
HIM MR. BLAKE WAS UNARMED AT THE
TIME HE WAS SHOT.
>> Tucker: SO IT IS SAD THAT
JACOB BLAKE GOT SHOT, SINCE
SERIOUSLY, IT IS ALWAYS SAD WHEN
PEOPLE GOT SHOT, WHETHER YOU
AGREE WITH THEM OR NOT, PERIOD.
BUT WHY JACOB LIQUID SHOT IS
KIND OF THE WHOLE POINT OF THE
STORY, ISN’T IT?
MR. BLAKE WAS UNARMED AT THE
TIME HE WAS SHOT, THAT’S WHAT
THEY TOLD US, AND YET SOMEONE IN
THE NEWS DIVISION FORGOT TO
CHECK WITH JACOB BLAKE ABOUT
THAT BECAUSE A WEEK LATER JACOB
BLAKE HIMSELF ADMITTED ON CAMERA
THAT HE WAS, IN FACT, ARMED.
>> I AM RATTLED.
I REALIZE I HAD DROPPED MY
KNIFE, MY POCKET KNIFE, SO I
PICKED IT UP AFTER I GOT OFF
WITH HIM, BECAUSE THEY TASED ME
AND I FELL ON TOP OF HIM.
I SHOULDN’T HAVE PICKED IT UP.
ONLY CONSIDERING WHAT WAS GOING
ON.
AT THAT TIME, I WASN’T THINKING
CLEARLY.
>> Tucker: OH.
JUST TO BE TOTALLY CLEAR, WE
FEEL SORRY FOR JACOB BLAKE.
HE GOT FOR IT HURT.
THAT WILL CHANGE HIS LIFE
FOREVER.
BUT IS NOT THE NEAT LITTLE
MORALITY TALE WE THOUGHT IT
WAS.
IS IT?
AND AGAIN, WE ARE NOT TELLING
YOU THAT, WE ARE NOT CORRECTING
THE LIE BECAUSE WE ARE SMUG AND
SELF-SATISFIED AND ENJOY
HIGHLIGHTING THE OTHER PEOPLE’S
ERRORS.
WE ARE JUST DEFENDING OUR NORMS
HERE, AS ANY AMERICANS WOULD.
IT JUST FEELS LIKE THE RIGHT
THING TO DO.
BUT IT IS A NEVER ENDING TASK.
TO GIVE MANY EXAMPLES, HERE’S
ONE FOR THE WEEKEND.
HUNDREDS OF ACTIVISTS GATHERED
IN NEW YORK TO STAGE A MARCH
AGAINST WHITE NATIONALISM,
SEEKING JUSTICE FOR AN
84-YEAR-OLD MAN FROM THAILAND
WHO HAD BEEN FLASHED WITH A BOX
CUTTER ON THE SUBWAY.
A LOT OF VIOLENCE ON NEW YORK
SUBWAY RIGHT NOW.
PROTESTERS STORMED THROUGH
WASHINGTON SQUARE PARK CHANTING
SLOGANS LIKE "WHOSE STREETS?
OUR STREETS!"
ONE HELD A SIGN THAT WHITE
NATIONALISM IS THE VIRUS.
MAYBE IT IS THE VIRUS BUT IT IS
HARD TO KNOW WHO HAS BEEN
INFECTED WITH.
POLICE HAVE NOW ARRESTED A 19
YEAR OLD MAN CALLED ANTON WATSON
FOR THE CRIME.
LET’S SAY IT IS HARD TO IMAGINE
THAT ANTON WATSON IS A WHITE
SUPREMACIST.
SO WHY ARE THEY SUGGESTING
OTHERWISE?
WHAT IS ALL OF THIS ABOUT?
WELL, HERE IS AN INTERESTING
THEORY, AND IT COMES TO US FROM
A RESEARCHER CALLED ZACH
GOLDBERG, WHO DOES NOT WORK AT
CNN, BY THE WAY.
OLD BIRD LOOK AT EVERY TIME RACI
AMERICA’S LARGEST NEWSPAPERS AND
NOTICED A NOTICEABLE SPIKE
JUST AFTER 2011.
NOT COINCIDENTALLY, WAS RIGHT
AROUND THE TIME OF THE OCCUPY
WALL STREET MOVEMENT, WHEN
PEOPLE WERE STARTING TO TALK
ABOUT WHAT WALL STREET ACTUALLY
DOES IN PUBLIC.
SUDDENLY, ALL AT ONCE,
JOURNALISTS AGREED THE REAL
PROBLEM IN AMERICA IS ITS
RACISM.
AMERICA IS NOT A PLACE WITH A
SCREWED OF ECONOMIC SYSTEM THAT
REWARDS A TINY NUMBER OF
EMOTIONALLY DAMAGED GRIFTERS WHO
POSSESS OTHERWISE USELESS SKILLS
APPLICABLE ONLY TO FINANCE AND A
PLACE WHERE EVERYONE ELSE --
PEOPLE IN FINANCE OR MAKING
MORE, BUT THAT IS NOT A PROBLEM.
OH, NO.
STOP TALKING ABOUT IT
IMMEDIATELY, AND THAT IS IN
ORDER.
NO, AMERICA IS INSTEAD, WE
LEARNED FROM A PLACE FOR THE
REST OF US MUST HATE EACH OTHER
AT ALL TIMES BECAUSE OF OUR SKIN
COLORS, WHICH BY THE WAY, CANNOT
BE CHANGED.
THAT WAY, ONCE WE ARE ALL
YELLING AT A GRIEVED AND ANGRY
ABOUT IRRESOLVABLE RACE
QUESTIONS, ONCE WE HAVE PICKED
THE WOUND UNTIL IT WON’T STOP
BLEEDING, WE WON’T HAVE THE TIME
TO ASK EVEN THE MOST BASIC
QUESTIONS ABOUT ECONOMICS.
QUESTIONS LIKE WHY DO ALL THESE
BE A LEANER HEDGE FUND GUYS PAY
HALF THE TAX RATE I
AM?
AND WHO PRECISELY IS GETTING
RICH FROM THE FEDERAL RESERVE?
WEARS ALL THAT MONEY GOING?
IT WOULD BE NICE TO KNOW.
YOU DO NOT SEE A TON OF STORIES
ABOUT THOSE QUESTIONS IN
"THE NEW YORK TIMES."
THEY ARE TOO BUSY TALKING ABOUT
RACE.
IT’S A PRETTY SOPHISTICATED
OPERATION, THIS COVER
WALL STREET OP, IF YOU THINK
ABOUT IT.
VLADIMIR PUTIN COULD NEVER PULL
IT OFF.
HE WOULD BY MIKE A FEW DOPEY ADS
ON FACEBOOK AND CALL IT A DAY.
IT TAKES A SOPHISTICATED
OPERATOR TO LIVE THIS
EFFECTIVELY, TO TAKE THE CENTRAL
PROBLEM OF AMERICAN LIFE, WHICH
IS THE AGONIZING DEATH OF OUR
MIDDLE CLASS, AND COVER IT WITH
A SMOKE SCREEN OF MANUFACTURED
RACE HATRED.
SO THAT NO ONE EVEN REALIZES
IT’S HAPPENING.
YOU REALLY NEED TO BE, WELL,
CNN WOULD PUT IT, A
DISINFORMATION NETWORK TO PULL
THAT OFF.
THE IRONY, BECAUSE EVERYTHING IS
IRONY, IS CNN ITSELF HAS BECOME
A DISINFORMATION NETWORK, MORE
POWERFUL THAN QANON AND FAR MORE